[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
je m'appelle
kelly
il ya du mou sakombi
un griot de l'afrique de l'ouest
[Musique]
la guinée conakry
alors que kelly c'est un griot
je ne suis pas un poète
mais un docteur
on
je suis un trio qui voyage
qui fait son observation
d'un autre mandat nous tous
[Musique]
le premier morceau
oh
il parle de la guerre
[Musique]
la guerre sa raison
dans toutes les guerres
du
c'est toujours
les innocent
qui meurt dans la guerre
tous
mes amis
[Musique]
chaque personne
on a deux à nous
le mal
et le bien
[Musique]
si on lui nourrit le mal
le bière il va disparaître
[Musique]
si on lit le bien
le mali va disparaître
[Musique]
donc il est temps de faire le bien
tél
[Musique]
indabawa
into éboulements l'aller marsannay brita
[Musique]
in port olona
mason et britta
[Musique]
hindawi moment là les masses année 8 à
manioc ses combos
à kebab et la
[Musique]
niña boukadoum en balineau
sayada monnaie des vidéos
des ragots
jambalaya lamoureux
[Musique]
winnie nyabou cadum hambaly non sayad la
momie des ragots de damballa
ça roulait
banino
[Musique]
oman
le
un commandant ben ali à manier
konami
[Musique]
thomas beatie barre à
oran day
[Musique]
l'eau
toujours la guerre on avait
[Musique]
un beau la mozambique c'est mabri et
contre tout
[Musique]
la côte d'ivoire
niger nigeria
aujourd'hui l'homme à lille au mali le
mali le mali le mali le mali le mali
[Musique]
ma maman
colonna
masanobu état
[Musique]
in terriblement là les français les
britanniques
[Musique]
un bocage normand balineau sayad la
momie et baby
[Musique]
gone
hammam
anyama
à la main
mariama
bâ
[Musique]
à la fin
reviens marianne uk
[Musique]
m
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
contre la barre à éléments
poutres la barre à yélimané et
toumaï et lehmann débat
mon collègue et les manadiers
contre le barrage et les mondes et oui
quand on a balayé les mâts d y ait
une âme un élément débat
moncaut day et les manades et
i5 os l'occasion
du colloque à 6 à
5 aux loquace ira web à
akalé marveaux cogner et
de corps des colons l'ont
dente wallon
vous sautez a créé dont du groupe
camada yelema mal
[Musique]
quand on dit le monde a changé
moi qui élit
je dis c'est pas vrai
[Musique]
le monde ne pas changer
c'est l'esprit de l'être humain
[Musique]
qui a basculé dans l'autre côté
sam pollock assira
du goulot qacida
5 au local s'il n'est pas
apte à l'imam ont cogné
doudou
de
[Musique]
à 2 à à
dounia
du lightning courrier ou ali à dubaï à
manier à dounia
addounia
piétiner qui me rouiller oulaya douliery
nikkei mardi comme un oiseau
3 / magnini à dimona
adria
a donné à
tous les acquis des kings courrier
wallahi adrien maeght à dubaï a
admis un
pliage et légumes des courriers williams
a dit
combien
la
[Musique]
matinée courrier ou ali à dubaï est
admis au
kiné qui met courrier wali
adriani
m
merci beaucoup lui
vous savez on peut dire la vérité avec
la loi
ok
alors certains comme un petit
composition qui j'ai fait pendant
tout ce temps de courcouronnes à virus
si on n'arrive pas à comprendre dans
quel pays on danse
chaque jour c'est notre rêve
les masques
[Musique]
l'isolément et nous sommes des êtres
humains c'était pas facile heures
[Musique]
m
surtout avec pourtant des informations
on était perdus
[Musique]
à tous ces maux marre
moi j'étais à la maison
[Musique]
parce que leur vie
on dirait que il est venu contre tout le
monde mais les artistes on a téléphoné à
[Musique]
gouesnou yayi qui me vaudra des
guillemets vaut la
peine ou iggy mourad aït
mouh
guillemets vos rollers
nearly bandits ki moon à bangui
inamine dei
d'allah on y
mon gars on y nous sommes rendus
au cours du débat où les la
biomasse la vie belle copie du film et
m'a vraiment son amie beth les mains
sourit il en est des
mobilités bas la fin où elle a
fait comme si fait comme ça mme amina
mama patati patata
on va chanter ensemble
c'est comme si vu comme ça m'a mis ma
main patati patata
c'est comme si
danone
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
abah abah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un ami m'a
patati peut-être
[Musique]
verra en a pâti gay
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]